With our HLOD system now explained,
that is going to bring us to the end of this video tutorial
series.
Now, in this video tutorial series,
we first started talking about optimization philosophies.
Remember, optimization is an ongoing process, something
that you will do throughout the lifetime of your project.
We then talked about optimizations that
can take place at project setup.
One of the things to remember here
is that anything you do in your project setup
will often require you restart the editor in order
to see that change take place.
We then took a look at texture optimizations.
Remember, textures need to remain in a power of 2
in the x or the y axis to get the most benefits out
of Unreal's built-in texture streaming technology.
We then took a look at ways to optimize
our static and skeletal meshes.
Remember, when you're dealing with static meshes that
are non-Nanite based, you will
need to create level of details for yourself
using the built-in tools.
Nanite does this for you automatically.
We also looked at ways we can apply LODs
to our skeletal meshes using Unreal's built-in level
of detail tools.
And remember, we can do this, and it will still
optimize our asset while keeping our animations properly
scanned.
We then took a look at how we can optimize our materials
using things like the parent material workflow,
as well as adding static switches and feature parameter
switches to help make sure that our materials perform
and look as they expect on our target platform.
We then took a look at some of the optimization of the modes
Unreal Engine 5 provides to help us visually
debug our levels lighting, texturing, and quad overdraw.
And then we took a look at a number of optimization tools
like Unreal's console command help section,
as well as Unreal's mesh merging and hierarchical level
of detail system that help you procedurally
make your meshes bind so that you can run projects faster
and more efficiently on whatever platform
you happen to be developing for.
Again, I want to thank you so much for following along
with me in this video tutorial series,
and I'll see you next time.